un très bel instrument très belle
lutherie surtout été choisi je
m'attendais pas à ce sont là
vu qu'on est sur une guitare qui pour
moi ça
en plus c'est une guitare sèche
vraiment guitare jazz
qui sont d'une conception va dire
différentes
sa prévalence être surpris ou même
séduit par l'instrument ce passionné de
guitare est justement venu pour ça le
salon de la lutherie d'issoudun et l'un
des plus renommés
chaque année la liste d'attenté longue
pour les luthiers voulant lui participer
autant forcément plus de gens ici quand
on est chez soi sur l'atelier tout ça
donc c'est important de se déplacer sur
les salons et de pouvoir montrer son
travail de pouvoir
dans un endroit concentré où il ya
beaucoup de musiciens de pouvoir faire
et ses instruments maximum de personnes
ici les jeunes fabricant côtoie les plus
grands noms franck cheval par exemple
bientôt 700 guitare à son actif parmi
ses clients francis cabrel ou johnny
hallyday après 35 ans de carrière un
instrument a sans doute sa préférence
princesse reçu pour marcel vaid il ya 28
ans est présenté au festival lors de sa
toute première édition et c'est une
guitare assez baroque avec un gros des
corps dans l'esprit micha avec les
choses un peu art nouveau
et puis cette guitare avait interpellé
francis cabrel qui était venu après me
voir donc c'était une guitare aussi
charnière pour moi mon travail de
luthier un peu voilà ça a été une
période importante
le festival de guitare d'issoudun se
termine ce soir
au programme une série de concerts en
hommage à son créateur marcel dadi vingt
ans après le décès de ce guitariste
virtuose